I'm joined today by Norman Oller who's
in New York Times bestselling author
novelists screenwriter and also author
of the book blitzed drugs and Nazi
Germany this is a very interesting topic
Norman and I'm curious how you first
started researching the topic of drugs
in Nazi Germany well it was a bit of a
street research because a friend of mine
who was a DJ in a Berlin underground
club for electronic music he told me
this he told me this story that a friend
of his is buying old furniture and
bought an old set of an old medicine
chest which had pervert een in it which
is methamphetamine he read on the on the
package the ingredient is
methamphetamine and he tried it and he
said it still worked even though it was
manufactured in the 40s that that
strange story got me interested and what
did you find out generally about drug
use and particularly methamphetamine use
among the not not just I mean of course
we can talk about the German military
and Nazis but more broadly among the
German people during the World War 2 era
well the Nazi dictatorship was a modern
performance-driven society so in 38 when
pervitin came on the market a perfectly
legal product containing methamphetamine
and the company who made it to Berlin
based company they said if you take this
pill I'm gonna be happy are you gonna
work better or you're gonna be yeah you
want to have more sex your life's just
gonna be a lot more fun and people are
always craving these things and
especially with craving this in Nazi
Germany
so pervitin became a huge hit even
chocolates came on the market which were
laced with methamphetamine no one
thought it would be a bad or dangerous
drug people just enjoy - housewives just
enjoyed their methamphetamine laced
chocolates so that everybody knows what
we're talking about we're not talking
about you know whether people are
starting to think about crystal meth in
its modern form or whatnot we're talking
here about a particular sort of blend
purva teen which does have the
stimulative effect of
amphetamine mild euphoria it's sort of
in a way also is is kind of like a
nootropic in the sense that it did
encourage sort of a focus and
concentration right I mean talk to us
generally about the effects of the drug
well actually it is
methamphetamine it was just produced in
a Berlin lab on the perfect condition so
you can't really compare it to street
meth right I mean but it's it's it's
like the original it was it was a German
invention a German product a high
quality product so when you took it the
new neurotransmitters in your brain were
released in a high fashion so you felt
alert and your brain was working
basically overtime so it felt like you
felt like your brain is working better
and and then of course at one point you
have to pay it back by the brain
becoming exhausted but people weren't
really talking about the side effects
back then they were just happy that this
new drug is on the market coffee wasn't
so available at the time and people
always crave a stimulant so a pill of
methamphetamine was the perfect drug for
Nazi Germany a lot of people have seen
the video of Adolf Hitler sort of
rocking back and forth in what sort of
colloquially might appear to some as
indicative of drug use what evidence do
we have related to drug use by Hitler
well fortunately his personal physician
Theo Morell kept a meticulous doctors
diary so we have a lot of days not every
day is recorded but thousands of days
between those two men Morell and Hitler
are recorded he became a Hitler's
personal physician in 1936 and was his
physician all the way to the end so we
we know we know what Hitler took and he
enjoyed especially one medicine which
was called oyakodon in Germany also
German patent the active ingredient is
oxycodone so we're talking about opiate
painkillers effectively in addition to
amphetamines Hitler wasn't using
methamphetamine Hitler was into opioids
no methamphetamine at all in other words
he took it once around Christmas 1944
one methamphetamine he took one pervert
in but he started in like pervert in
pervitin with witches methamphetamine
was basically a drug for the normal
common folk and it was a drug for the
army to keep the soldiers running what
was the the official reason if there was
one for which Hitler was taking the
opiate painkillers well people around
him were wondering hip Himmler was was
was wondering what is actually in those
daily injections he was getting between
patient Hitler patient a as Morel called
him and Morel there was they didn't
speak to third persons about this so
Morel was just his doctor and Hitler
said I have stomach cramps I want my
oxycodone then he got twenty milligrams
injected intravenously and he was
extremely high and happy and thought
that Morel was a very good doctor there
are people who have criticized your book
reviewers saying that even if you're not
making explicit this claim that a reader
could come away thinking that the
rampant drug use by Hitler by other
Nazis in some way absolves them from
some culpability during World War 2 and
the Holocaust well have you heard that
criticism before I'm guessing the answer
is yes and how do you respond to that
well I've heard this criticism it's
actually a rare criticism most people do
not have this criticism but there's some
I don't know what I don't know why they
make this Christian because I can't
really understand it I mean in Germany
we have the law let's say you plan to
murder someone and then for doing it you
drink two beers in German all this
doesn't lessen your responsibility for
the crime
sure and the crimes were not done by the
Nazis by Hitler because they took drugs
it was not like a good Hitler and sudden
he takes drugs becomes a bad Hitler
commits these crimes so actually not him
it's not the nods it's not the ideology
it's just the drugs that's just not true
the drug the drugs play a very important
role for the regime to to exercise their
power but it does not it does not
explain or excuse the crimes or the
Holocaust that those crimes have
everything to do with the Nazi ideology
which is a fascist ideology which is a
right-wing ideology which doesn't like
the other which is aggressive which is
racist that those are those are the good
but that kind of thinking and
policymaking that's what caused these
horrible crimes not the drugs but it's
very interesting to see how the drugs
were being used and what effects it had
it's a very it's it's very interesting
you get a very clear picture of how it
actually worked
yeah and I guess my next question is
about that which is now that we've
gotten the sort of culpability question
aside could the drug use or do you
believe that the rampant drug use
impacted the course of how the war went
well I think basically the answer is yes
and no which is another satisfactory but
Germany would have lost the war in any
case it was not possible to win world
war two for Germany they had early
successes in the so-called blitzkrieg
which means speed war which is a
strategy to move extremely fast and to
surprise the enemy by moving faster than
he can think and that's what the Germans
did in Poland and in France and for
those campaigns they used a lot of
methamphetamine to keep soldiers awake
for three four days and nights this is
what surprised the enemy the Western
Allies this is what's the price Church
and he said to his French colleague
Bella gee when the Germans were so fast
he said they will have to rest every
human being needs to sleep they will
sleep at night and then we can you know
get closer and they're not gonna be that
fast for like a whole week but the
Germans were because they were pumped
full with methamphetamine that's a very
interesting fact and you can research
that very closely with the documents
that are still available in the military
archive in Germany so telling that story
just gives you a better idea of how
World War two actually was for
but it doesn't excuse anything to say
that one more last time yeah did any of
the allies start to think hey what if we
also look into using amphetamines well
the beginning the Allies simply did not
know there were all kinds of rumors why
the Germans are so good such good
fighters the myth of the unbeatable
Velma is so into Hitler that actually
they can fight better but that was all
not true they were just messed up I mean
it's just like a sports person totally
using the right doping agents I mean it
just gives you an advance in an
advantage in a physical combat situation
so can you do we have the Allies at any
point start to also say what this is
something we could look at doing well as
information about not necessarily the
use of the meth but just let's figure
out ways to keep our soldiers awake
longer
yeah the British found out in late 1940
there was an article in an Italian paper
which talked about the courage pill
which the German pilots were using then
the Royal Air Force did their own tests
and they actually agreed with the
Germans they said it's good to take
amphetamines they said it's not good to
take methamphetamine that's too strong
for the British soldier but let's take
amphetamines and they supplied the
troops then with amphetamines so in the
later phase of the war British we're
fighting on amphetamines against the
Germans on methamphetamines and then
when the Americans joined the European
theater they were also being given the
infant amines through the British troops
so the Americans actually still are
using a stimulants basically all armies
in the world are trying to figure out
which stimulants to use a lot of armies
are using stimulants the Nazis were the
forefathers in this unholy a trade or
holy trade however you see it by doping
their men to achieve a better military
result Norman the book is fascinating
it's called blitzed drugs in Nazi
Germany and we've been speaking with the
book's author Norman Oller who's in New
York Times bestselling
I really appreciate you talking to us
about this it was a pleasure thank you